told you they were running out of  corners exactly this is a pretty ball  and a great over-the-shoulder catching  right into the pylon  he does his job he stuffs it and then he  switches off  and that gave kj the time to throw that  ball  and it's a perfectly thrown ball right  over the outstretch arm of eli rix  right into the end zone this gets a  busted coverage number one  and number two your safety misses a  touchdown saving tackle that time  there's a nice juke to the inside to get  that  final outside burst i know but when you  got the sideline  [Applause]  costello looked left lobs it to the  corner a touchdown  500 yards passing and austin williams  for the school  stuttering really bad technique that  time  barely got his hands on him was out of  phase before he even moved  a pair of fives but it's the marine five  that wins it